il y a Loïc perron qui dit en parlant de
vous oui enfin ce record de l'Atlantique
c'est seulement un convoyage retour un
peu rapide
la Route du Rhum si elle y participe je
vous assure qu'elle sera pas un client
sérieux vous l'avez vu depuis le début
bonsoir alors vous suivez un petit peu
les illuminatoires de la de l'américain
à la coupe du huit ans
à la RAM que les éliminatoires de la
Coupe plus vite
ça m'a jamais facile c'est de la voile
donc forcément ça m'intéresse mais c'est
assez loin de ce qu'on fait finalement
c'est très c'était très technique ça
concerne au milieu de
la Formule 1 si on veut c'est non c'est
la tactique c'est de la régate c'est de
la tactique de régate c'est pas c'est
pas de la merde
c'est encore mieux parce que bon c'est
vrai qu'il faut être apparemment elle
serait complètement désespéré pour
partir à traverser Atlantique et la RAM
et Peggy avait seulement envie de passer
l'an 2000 en mer tranquille toute seule
et elle avait tenté la dernière fois de
faire il y a de le faire et elle avait
chaviré au bout de 79 jours juste avant
d'arriver en Guadeloupe cette fois-ci
elle a choisi d'arriver en Martinique et
elle a réussi c'est bien alors surtout
bonsoir
vous êtes dans 57 j'ai grandi dans le
16e
dans un quartier où on fait le mur pour
des institutions religieuses pour sortir
et alors à 17 ans j'ai une accident de
voiture très très grave j'ai fait 7
tonneaux et ben c'est 6 mois à Garges
vous étiez défigurés et je sais pas
comment parce que vous étiez comment
avant en tout cas ça se voit pas du tout
hein
on s'y habitue ça a été ma chance
finalement cet accident ça m'a permis de
me sortir un petit peu de de
mon milieu et puis de ce qui m'était
destiné parce que cette époque
l'accident non mais en fait ça a été une
période de deux ans de convalescence ou
on va passer tous les caprices parce que
fallait surtout pas me contredire sinon
je risque de rester un peu coincé et en
fait j'avais le droit de rien faire
euh ni au niveau des études parce que
j'étais pas très pas très vivant
intellectuellement et ni au niveau
sportif à part du bateau on m'a autorisé
à faire du bateau donc je suis parti
très assez Atlantique et ensuite j'ai
fait ma après
vous étiez au à l'école de voile et vous
disiez vous dites en parlant de cette
époque parfois je vais me cacher pour
pleurer c'était dur cet apprentissage
c'est toujours c'est toujours difficile
parce que quand on est mousse on fait
tous les sale boulot et on a aucun enfin
aucune récompense mais c'est comme ça
que le métier rentre alors 78 était là
benjamine dans la Route du Rhum c'est la
première Route du Rhum 78 et ma première
aussi et vous avez gagné votre surnom de
petite fiancés de l'Atlantique en 90
vous battez le record de traverser de
l'Atlantique en solitaire en août et à
ce moment-là il y a Loïc perron qui dit
en parlant de vous après ce record oui
enfin ce record de l'Atlantique c'est
seulement un court de retour un peu
rapides la Route du Rhum si elle y
participe je vous assure qu'elle sera
pas un client sérieux vous l'avez vu
depuis
deux jours
et en novembre vous gagnez la Route du
Rhum sur sur pierre 1er vous l'avez revu
Loïc perron vous êtes expliqué là-dessus
il y a souvent des petits trucs qui
peuvent l'échapper comme ça de temps en
temps et puis il ne manque pas de me
laisser un message sur mon répondeur oh
t'inquiète pas je voulais pas dire ça
vous gagnez la Route du Rhum donc
Jean-Pierre premier et alors là vous
devenez une star évidemment nationale
j'ai retrouvé des papiers de l'époque on
disait de Florence Arthaud la nana qui
se décourage pas quand sarado sa radio
pardon tombe en miette et quand elle a
une panne de pilote automatique elle
barre pendant 24 heures sur 24 pendant 5
jours
24 je barrais je barrais 20 à 22h sur 24
enfin 23h je dormais deux trois
demi-heure par jour c'est vrai donc
vous chantez donc avec Pierre Bachelet
effectivement et là tout est fini la
société pierre 1er qui était votre
sponsor vend le bateau
et vous commencez
de briser une carrière comme ça juste
avec et alors là vous commencez à
galérer pour trouver un sponsor à partir
de là et vous faites des non mais
sérieusement là vous avez du mal après
passer beaucoup de temps à chercher non
plus j'ai profité de cette petite
interruption pour aller naviguer sur le
bateau des autres finalement c'est pas
c'est pas si désagréable que ça on a
tous les avantages sans avoir les
inconvénients et aussi le le poids et la
responsabilité d'un équipage d'un bateau
en construction qui est tout le temps
moitié cassé et je fais ça depuis
maintenant 8 ans vous avez fait des
courses vous avez fait le Figaro sur bal
espoir alors quand on vous parlez du
Figaro vous dites
en solitaire plutôt que de rester à quai
je me suis mise au Figaro Bénéteau la
mer c'est mon gagne pas vous dites ça
d'une façon un peu comme ça un peu blasé
un peu cynique et puis de la même année
vous dites je souffre lorsque je le
navigue pas donc vous préférez naviguer
sur un Figaro Bénéteau pour rester à
terre
j'ai essayé de rester un peu à terre
l'hiver dernier et puis bon ça me ça me
manque trop et puis c'est vrai que c'est
mon gagne pas
cet été vous faites quoi donc vous
faites le Figaro là ce soir Fleury
Michon fait Florian Saint-Barth vous le
faites voilà
en double avec Philippe Poupon sur la
saison en solitaire toute seule quoi
Porquerolles aussi
le Figaro dans le golfe de Gascogne
au milieu des vous avez beaucoup
Florence Arthaud je crois Richard
personne humaine magnifique
je le dis sans aucune
ce qu'elle a fait ce qu'elle est comme
ça ce que je sais c'est marrant de
rechercher ce que tout le monde fuie en
fait pour chercher la solitude et
globalement les gens se battent pour ne
pas justement être seul dans la vie je
recherche
c'est pas un abandon un abandon affectif
en fait c'est une solitude enrichissante
où on se retrouve en fait avec soi-même
et qui nous aide à vivre pour le reste
de la vie c'est c'est des bons moments
qu'on part chercher dans la solitude et
avec des il y a quand même où on peut
avoir ce genre de sensation se retrouver
seul avec soi-même mais bon on n'est pas
seul on se rend compte qu'on est
vraiment pas seul quand on est en mer
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu